develop new therapies this is what I
want to do because I said that I'm G but
at the end of the day you want to
develop and to do one trial and to make
sure that everyone in the world can use
it and can trust it and it's not a basic
science at the end of the day people are
going to be tweeted um with this uh
based on these results so you need to do
a very accurate study which will be
multicenter multinational study at the
end of the day you want the European
United States something in Japan
everyone will accept these results so
it's a very interesting very very
straightforward you need to be very very
accurate but you need to be able to act
in a worldwide
[Music]
environment welcome to 20 minute leaders
welcome to this show over the next uh 20
minutes we'll dive into your world the
world of Yol
uncover really cool acronyms that I have
haven't heard of before I got a chance
to to invite you to the show and and and
so um as I mentioned to you before I I
expect uh quite a few people to not know
a lot of the things that we will be
talking about today so this is a a an
introduction for me and this is an
introduction for everybody listening so
I'm I'm I'm excited to to enable a
platform for that experience and so
thank you again for being here very much
welcome thank you for having me yes and
master you know Michael I'm I'm a
clinical child geek so I need to deliver
very clearly you know all the acronyms
and all the things about clinical trial
because I think this is
fascinating I mean it's it's the basis
for so much of the medicine that we have
and the operational work that we do on
our bodies and minds and how we treat
experimentation when it comes to
Medicine you know when I uh when I velop
AI systems um as a as a startup and for
software and for analytics um I do my
trials you know on different cloud
services and data that comes in and when
when when hits the fan then you
know we can reproduce and run things H
and and you get to do this in the
physical world in in much higher stakes
and much more H important I think uh
areas and so um tell me a little bit
about
you know your world and and what does
this mean for you to be a a geek of
clinical
trials so you know when I started my
professional life I started a PhD in wi
span Institute and I said after one year
and a half I said okay so what this what
I'm going to do I think it's fascinating
but it's not for me to stay next to the
bench I said Okay I want to be the
professional side and then I left my PhD
and I started to learn an MBA in the
Hebrew University in Jerusalem
um and very quickly I said okay develop
new therapies this is what I want to
do um why because I said that I'm G but
at the end of the day you want to
develop and to do one trial and to make
sure that everyone in the world can use
it and can trust it and it's not a basic
science at the end of the day people are
going to be tweeted um with this uh
based on this results so you need to do
a very accurate study which will be
multicenter m multinational study at the
end of the day you want the European
United States sometimes in Japan
everyone will accept these results so
it's a very interesting very very
straightforward you need to be very very
accurate but you need to be able to act
in a worldwide environment with so many
Multicultural different Multicultural
environment and to execute exactly the
same project
on the same time all over the
world absolutely okay so that that's a
pretty pretty sounds like a complex task
to to uncover wh why is this important
for us why is this say what what you
know if if this is done successfully
what does it enable what what impact
does it have on our society on Humanity
on our ability to progress Health
forwards so almost everything starts
with clinical trial all the health care
that you know all the treatment all the
devices everything it must start with a
clinical trial and if you think about
how many
basic um research you have in the
academic world people are trying to look
for a lot of things but at the end of
the day you need to say okay you have
this idea now we need to be able to put
it in a way that at the end of the day
it's w just be like a prean
just a basic search why is this
important and you said it all starts
with clinical
trials yeah so you think all think about
the world that we know it's it looks to
you like obious you going to your a
physician you're getting your
prescription you can go to the pharmacy
you get you get you get it you know your
drug but before that there was a lot of
efforts that can bring you to the point
that someone can write can give it to
you um and all the time want to develop
better drugs better treatments better
medical devices and everything must be
approved everything must be accurate so
everything start with a clinical trial
that at the end of that you can submit
the data to the Regulatory Agencies you
know to the FDA to the European
regulatory different Regulatory Agencies
and say I have a solution it's accurate
and it's safe okay so let let's dive
into the data because data is is where
you know it sounds like this is is where
the the core of it that's the the most
important aspect what are the different
what are the I guess the aspects that
make the data safe or make it secure in
a way that would be accepted then as as
reputable
data
so when I want to start and and give
this proof to the to the regulatory
agency that my medical device of the
drug is safe and I and and and effective
first of all I need to after I did like
all the preclinical test I need to draft
the protocol saying this is a plan this
is how I'm going to do the clinical
trial you have a few phases and you have
a few PL protective as as a side because
all of them are exactly the same meaning
this is a plan the plan need to be
approved by the ethic committee and then
after you been approved you need to go
and approach the medical centers or the
hospitals and say this is a plan I want
you do it in your in your in your
facility agreement is signed between
between this clinical trial sponsor the
medical device or the Pharm company and
the medical center and then the study
can start meaning you can start enoll
patients and treat them with your novel
therapy now think about it that as
you're moving in the different stages of
getting approved at the beginning we're
just saying that it's safe after that
you were saying it's safe and and
effective and then you want to do it in
a big scale that it's um to show that
it's statistic statistically significant
Improvement and then you need to do the
study all over the world okay think
about in an average oncolog oncology
study an average fate three oncology
trial with 3,000 patient all over the
world 70 medical centers it can be you
need to collect exactly the same data
with the same interval from the same po
population of spti it's almost the oppos
in said for big data and metadata
analysis you want specific data from
specific patients in specific
intervals so how do you collect this
data right now there is no integration
with all the medical centes and there is
no way to take the data out of the
electronic health record the EHR first
Eon today many so you need to get it and
you need to put it in the clinical trial
database we call it the EDC electronic
data C
but there is no connectivity so how do
you get this data people at the medical
centers data managers need to sit with
two screens and copy the data for one
screen from the ehl screen to the EDC to
the clinic trial database screen now in
any industry if you copy data manually
you have
mistakes but there is no way you can
submit data with inaccurate data to the
Regulatory
Agencies so
the clinical trial sponsor the Pharma or
the medical device company sent
representative to the medical centers
and what they do again they sit with to
screen and verifying all the data fade
three onology trial we collect more than
3.6 million data
points the majority of these data points
been captured and verified
manually wow there is no other way to do
it so far it's a very very M Power
Market yes and it's a so it's a it's a
two it's a two-step system right it's
the capture is done in well it's three
steps so the capture is done in the
device and then you have a human that
transfers from the EA CH to EDC and then
on top of that you have an additional H
verifier so that hopefully if you made
some mistake in the in the trans in the
transmission from EHR to EDC you now
have somebody catching that and then the
regulation hopefully says okay maybe
this is good enough
right yes and according to a lot of the
research that viam for data that was
submitted to the FDA even after this
verification process yeah still in every
study we have between five to s%
mistakes five to s% mistakes that's a
lot it's a lot of
mistakes so you need to you need to
enroll more patients into the study in
order to mask the mistakes that you have
makes sense no know having I guess
having more a bigger sample size sounds
like a good thing generally H but uh but
but it sounds like it's not being done
for the right reasons or or the right
motivations necessarily um why is it
difficult so or or is it difficult I
mean what what is sort of the you know
why did why didn't they come a few years
ago and say hey I guess we shouldn't be
doing this manual H copying why don't we
connect these end points together and
have some software that do that does the
data transmission what what's what's
been happening in the market that made
this a
gap you know as a tech people you
usually said that the technology is one
step ahead of the regulation and the
people in the government offices need to
chase after the changes that is
happening in the real world over here
it's just the opposite scenario the FDA
published in 2018 says guys enough is
enough with manual process start
streaming data connect the vhr directly
to the edcs to the clinic and database
even the EMA the European um the
European regulatory agency said Guys
these are the these are the fundamentals
this is how we should do that please
follow and yet there is
no solution in the market the reason for
that is also because of the
technology even if two two different
medical centers has the same EHR the
same electronic health record you still
have
different um modification with it so
there was almost no way to do like on a
scale yeah like you have one solution
you can stream all the
data um and from the other end all the
different adcs this system been designed
to capture the data manually so for
every study they need to they needed to
do like a new or a new integration so
almost these two two different sides eh
child and the
edcs they don't know how to speak with
each
other it's super interesting and and
tell me a little bit about your
background so what what got you
here
so so my background as I said I have a
master degree in life science and also
an MBA and I I worked in the clinical
industry for 20 years and some um
sometime during 2018 when I saw the FDA
guidance I started to dive into this
problem because I walk with the Char I
walk with the ADC and I said it doesn't
make sense the FDA is pushing the
industry instead of being the opposite
way um and in 2019 I joined my
co-founder gav Mel and we decided okay
guys we are going to be the guys that
are going to solve this EHR 3DC and we
are going to build the solution for
that and was this a no-brainer for host
hospitals or the the labs to to adopt
did they look at this and say oh where
where have you been my whole life I've
been copying manually and now I get to
do this what is what has been the
response because there must have been
some some level of Education or some
level of of assurance that you have to
do I I notice I I go on the on the
website there's a you know a big
beautiful section showing probably more
compliance logos than than I've seen in
a long time
yes so it's very difficult because you
need to be compliant with all the
clinican regulation with all the EHR
regulation and with all the gdpr hi
integration so it's very it's a very
highly regulated industry right so and
and and and this is what he said if it
was easy you know everyone could do that
but you need to do you need to convince
first of all you know no one was fired
because they work with
IBM um and and people are saying you
know the company invested 50 million 770
million just to get to the point that
they have a clinical trial so it's say
okay guys copy data manually it's
accepted by the FDA it's safe let's
invest another a few Millions let's do
it in the manual way streaming I get it
that it's more quick that it's quicker
it's maybe safer but let's do the the
manual way because this is we know that
this is this is okay with FDA so it's
it's it's a very tough Market in clean
in general the healthcare Market it's
it's very hard to
disrupt and to change habit and it's
it's very very slow so we starting with
a small startup moving to a bigger
companies the big farmas the fisers they
are going to be the last one to adopt
this kind of Technology interesting
interesting okay so that makes sense to
me we're playing sort of the long game
and looking three four years into the
future how do you envision the space so
right now you can see when you look at
about the data Bas of the clinical trial
they mentioned the edcs you right now
it's it's just a fancy it's just a fancy
Excel because it was a system that
develop to capture the data manually you
have small DCS with three very talented
people that um developers that made a
very nice and advanced up to companies
with you know with thousands of
employees and you have hundred of
players like that because it's a simple
system we inv that in the few years you
would see consolidation of this market
and instead of hundred of players you
will have I don't know five 10 very
strong players that knows how to
integrate with thousands of different
ehrs harmonize the data and put it in
the right field in the in the database
um and I think this is where the market
goes from hundred of players to a very
limited number of because it's a
different players because it's it's a
different game to capture the data
manually or to stream it absolutely and
how do you feel your experience in the
Life
Sciences besides having a very good
understanding as to the problem and
having experienced the problem firsthand
how do how do you find your background
being relevant here in other words you
know I'm I'm thinking through there's so
many different opport incredible
opportunities in the Life Sciences in
general especially this now with with
the Transformations that were were given
through a Computing trips and hardware
and and and AI technology so I'm I'm
curious how you see the barrier to of
Entry to this complex organism called
the healthc care industry which is so
difficult to disrupt and and you you
have to really understand it what what
would be sort of your advice to to other
entrepreneurs that may be be growing
passions for these types of markets but
they're not sure of whether their
background is suitable to enter the
space so you have two different approach
how to or two different ways to approach
this Market one is usually you said have
a very cool technology let's see how it
can fit into this Healthcare market and
sometimes it works it works only if and
it works only if you have a very very
strong technology and I will get to it
in a second the second approach is okay
this is a problem let's find the
technology to solve
it so I think the magic is usually to do
the to try and combine them so because
you if you want the healthcare industry
to to to use your technology you must
solve them a real real problem yeah um
and by the way and and what we see we
even with a even with the VIS I'm saying
okay we are getting that this is a real
problem so we're willing to give you
more time and more Capital because at
the end of the day everyone gets the
data will be streamed from the h2c we
are not going to to continue copying
copy data for for years
ahead so the only question if it's going
to be on link or it's going to be a
different company and there are strong
competit for but everyone gets the data
is going to be streamed so when you have
a real problem and a strong technology
so the VCS are willing to give you more
time and more Capital because they know
that this solution is going to be solved
and I think this is the most important
you need to know that you're solving a
real real problem
that that's where it all starts from I
completely agree Ido what are you get
most excited by so what what really
pequs your energy and your interest in
the
day-to-day uh first of all it's my
family okay this is really this is my
energy um so you know seeing my kids
growing this is a this is the most
important thing for me but after that I
would
say I said I said it's the beginning you
know we started the company I lived in
chano but we registered the company in
Israel and for the first time when I sat
in my home in a small kibuts next to
Jerusalem and I saw the data streamed
from an EHR in Stanford I said wow this
is where we need to be I need to be able
to sit in a small in my home at 11:30
p.m. and see the data of a patient that
just came for a visit in Stanford in the
west coast this is where we want to be
amazing I I love it you know thank you
so much for the time and the H the
presence and the energy U really
appreciate it and uh This was um eye
opener for me in in many ways
particularly to a new industry but also
to some very fundamentals that are
taking place that are not uh that I
think that another other Industries
wouldn't even fathom having yet an
industry such so critical like that of
the clinical trials obviously still has
a lot of areas to grow so thank you very
much for the time and I really
appreciate it okay thank you for having
me take care amazing